heads up guys my name is China welcome
back to the series where I recreate my
first game that remain in Java in C plus
plus using a different microphone this
time so let me know how that sounds all
right let's just get straight into it
honestly because we've got so much work
to do last episode we talked about
static this doesn't even build at the
moment great but last episode we talked
about static and whether or not like
things should be static class instances
should be static how to deal with that
stuff I'll have that linked up there
because of that though we didn't really
get much work done so hopefully today
we're going to actually spend our time
programming uh because we need to get
this shot on the road because this game
needs to be shipped everyone's waiting
for it obviously so let's get this going
one thing that we did in the episode
before the previous episode was we
talked about how to actually get uh you
know Sprites out of a Sprite sheet so we
basically have this thing that we refer
to as a Sprite sheet which is this guy
over here all of our Sprites all of our
little like textures I guess are inside
one texture inside one image it's like
one PNG file I think
um the pink kind of when the pink and
the purple are kind of transparent
colors we use that instead of making
this like a normal rgba texture and
having an alpha Channel there's no real
like technical reason for that that's
just how this game happens to have been
made and we're going to try and recreate
it here in C plus plus without modifying
the assets at all so whatever this is
that's kind of like our little challenge
if you will to stick to the same kind of
situation
um so now that we can kind of render
this stuff there's a few things that I
want to take a look at first of all uh
we need to abstract our code
um into something that resembles a
renderer and we actually started already
creating a renderer class so we'll
continue on with that kind of trend and
then the second thing that I would like
to take a look at soon is probably
adding support for animation so you can
see that this player model over here has
like six different Sprites well I guess
there's two for each Direction and
there's only one for rights because okay
this guy doesn't exist by the way ignore
him that was a test during let him down
uh so this is the real player Sprite we
don't have a kind of a Sprite that faces
left because we can just flip this
Sprite so that's why that's kind of made
like that um but for the kind of you
know facing up and facing down there's
two of these guys because the there's
like an animation he kind of alternates
and actually I believe they're supposed
to be three
um I think that you can flip this guy
horizontally as well because see how his
foot is like it's only like the left
foot when he's facing away uh but it
should alternate maybe to the right foot
so if you flip that whole Sprite and
then you'll get the same thing but you
know with his foot here instead and it
looks like it's his right foot so maybe
it needs to go like you know if this is
like you know index 0 index one then we
go back to index zero and then we flip
to index one but flipped and that's kind
of like number two and then we go back
to zero so it's like zero one zero one
flipped zero one zero one flipped that
might be the sequence of Animation
although we can always look at the
original Java code probably to see how
that works but anyway
um what I'm going to do is to start off
with let's actually Implement that
renderer so we started kind of talking
about and then we got hung up with the
whole static thing but we do have two
kind of image renderers that we
basically made here and like a static
kind of uh instance I guess of game
layer I also wanted to take out this
game layer class and actually make it a
separate file so we might also do that
um okay so this is how we rendered the
Sprite uh ideally what we would probably
want to do
is we talked about this as well
I just need to remember what we did
because the series is of course entirely
live no planning so I'm trying to do
things on the Fly and show you guys how
I think
um so
we had all of these static tiles here
which we decided were a little bit silly
to have but what what is important with
it
um is the surprise as well by the way a
static is of course the index of the
Sprite so we do still need some place
where we can Define these kind of
coordinates because what these
coordinates map to are like the X and
the Y index from within that Sprite
sheet right so the X and the Y uh of
where this is by cell and I think we
discovered it was from the top right so
you know this guy over here would for
example be 2 1 right this guy
um so that still needs to be stored
somewhere we still need kind of like
that to be
defined somewhere
um but it just doesn't need to be an
instance of the Sprite class and then
hopefully what we can do is go into the
screen class which is the renderer
probably copy most of this code I don't
know if I should copy it or if I should
just write it like I would these days
maybe that would be better
um and then we can kind of render it and
then we also have to provide an offset
so maybe let's try and do that maybe
let's try and render somewhat of a tile
map today
uh using that renderer class so
how do I want to begin
um so we do need some kind of image to
render to and I think that what we
probably should do is create
um I think I want to tie this renderer
directly to an image so I think what
what we can do is maybe just create a
renderer that actually takes in
um a like a walnut image
2D right is that what it's called or
it's probably just an image
um it takes in uh like a Target kind of
image so we'll include walnuts
image
walnuts
image so we have that shared pointer
being taken in here and it's actually
going to store like a reference to that
it probably doesn't even like it could
create its own image I think that would
also be okay but then it has to deal
with resizing it and we already kind of
did that
um and that way I guess we can just
provide an image we don't have to it can
store the image so that it has a
contacts to render two
[Music]
um
but I guess the other thing is at the
end of the day you know we could also
just store
the image of data there
[Music]
um
because we kind of need that as well
don't we
because maybe we don't even need the
image
because we have image set data image
data yeah let's do that instead maybe
it's just that this also does need to be
resized though
um so that's also another consideration
okay so there's a few things we could do
I think I am probably just gonna
make this be completely almost separate
from from walnuts so we won't have
Walnut like at all here and we will just
have this but then the question is do we
I guess we would just let's let's just
have this kind of
create like a renderer of a certain size
so we might have like an initial width
and height for the image
um and then we can have like a get image
data
maybe I'll call it get image buffer
that will return that
and then what I can do is I can also add
like a kind of on resize
um and then what that will do is
obviously take this in
we should definitely hold the width and
the height which I'll just uh set to
zero initialize to zero initialize this
to non-pointer
um and then what we'll do is
this should be in Genesis name space
Genesis let's just quickly implement
this you should using visual assist
um okay so we'll do M width width
thanks visual studio for these errors
much appreciated
oh actually I may have done something
wrong somewhere
no
I think it just is it really just the
type
yeah standard int.h includes these kinds
of type definitions
um okay and then we'll do um
image equals
I guess we'll call this image buffer
equals new un32t with
or am with doesn't really matter times
height uh on resize basically does that
so we'll get it to delete the old one
um I think also like if we really wanted
to we could uh
how about we change this to be like
resize
if needed
and then that way we can kind of just
make this be like if uh width is width
and height is height
then we'll return so that way if the
stored width and height is the same as
what it already is here we can just skip
that otherwise we'll assign these guys
um and then actually do the resize
basically which will just do that and
then like if we wanted to we could like
clear at this point in time
um
again the the the main the like the the
game in Java didn't actually have this
like it didn't have resizing you
launched it like that there's no
resizing so this is kind of a new
feature so we can't really copy the
strategy directly here but I guess we
probably should do some kind of clearing
here
um because if we don't then
like obviously we've just deleted the
old one created a new one of a different
width and height
you would probably want to then do
rendering so this is probably the first
thing you would do
um so kind of like I think what we did
here with resizing potentially yeah so
this was kind of like the resizing that
happened
and then you can see we changed image
data to be scaled window width and
height so basically what we've done is
we've kind of taken away this because
we've abstracted that away into the
renderer class
and so now what we have instead
um we don't need this anymore we can
keep that if we want and we can just set
it to not take anything in if we want
um and then when we create the renderer
which I'm going to
ah it doesn't really matter it doesn't
really matter does it we could make it a
shared pointer like it already is here
but it honestly doesn't matter so we'll
have a renderer here
ah this can go away
um well actually we'll keep that because
we'll use that in a minute uh we'll
create the renderer here
with 96540 which again is kind of
arbitrary uh we probably should set it
up
to be creative maybe one one a size is
actually needed
um and then what we'll do is
basically on UI render so this is where
the resize supposedly happens which as
you can see is after we've kind of drawn
the image but remember the image still
needs to be resized however the renderer
because the image is kind of like yeah I
don't know if I like this too much
because
even though it keeps the renderer kind
of separated from Vulcan entirely and
it's like this is like just a software
Android there still needs to be like an
image that gets kind of you know sent to
the GPU in a way it already like it's a
texture it's an image that exists on the
GPU and then we need to like make sure
it's the right size and then like upload
the buffer of data from the CPU to the
GPU every frame but what we've kind of
done with this design I guess is we've
kind of made it so that the renderer
and the image are two dislikes discrete
kind of separate beings and that might
not be good because now it falls onto
like us it has to be our responsibility
now to keep them in sync which I don't
know if I like that
um
because you can see why hopefully
because again like even though this guy
has the actual image buffer I am now
responsible for making sure that for
example when the uh window changes
like I have to resize my own image now
wait I don't think I like that
like I feel like in a way it should just
be separate from this so I'm actually
going to go back and redesign it a bit
now it's not gonna it's not gonna change
our image buffer situation
[Music]
um
because that still should that still
needs to be there that's our primary
render Target but it's just gonna also
take on this kind of image that we have
here so I'll cut that image out
I'll pop it into here
um I'll bring back you know Walnut
um
and
this is probably a a joke
really
did we not
so shared pointers and stuff are stored
in memory and I had a file called memory
without the H
as I keep bringing the H in
which I'm sure has the standard hint as
well so we can get rid of that but
that's a bit weird I thought that would
have been there
um yeah now we just kind of tie these
two together so we just have an image
and its buffer if that makes sense and
then we can obviously need to we
obviously need to create this with the
format as well so we can just take you
know uh this
and then maybe you know width and height
so we'll create that we've got that
we've got the image buffer which by the
way we should definitely add a
Destructor
not necessarily definitely but it's good
to do that
um because we might recreate the
renderer maybe I'm not sure but that
will just release the buffer
um we've got the image which we can now
get rid of so now the renderer just
takes in a size that's kind of it uh all
of this stuff you know we can kind of
um you know
clear with random
colors
so we can do I'll just call it clear
random this is an English essay
so clear random is just like a probably
a utility function which we'll delete
later but it's just good for testing and
that will just do this
so I'll go through width times height
which I thought that's at width
times height and just do image buffer
I equals Walnut random
uint so it's kind of taking that away
um
we will do it so the resize if needed
will also kind of go back to here
and
recreate the image
um with width and height so the scaling
we will still obviously need to do
outside of this class because that's
kind of irrelevant
um yeah and that basically makes all
that go away I think and then finally we
still need the image descriptor set so
we can have get image buffer even though
we probably won't use that and then
really it's this it's going to be a
function called get image
that's going to return M image
and then that way to get this we can
just do M renderer and get image and
then get descriptor set
um now the width and the height you can
see we do width times image scale
because the image here is actually going
to be at a different size so this is
also something that we potentially need
to think about because uh is the
renderer aware of its size and I think
it might
but no because the actually the images
the image is the same
yeah so I guess we just do we do we do
use scaled window width and height just
like we did here so we'll kind of think
about that
um but for now we'll leave that as is so
basically what I'm saying is that the
width and height of this buffer and the
image will always be tied together it
kind of has to be anyway because
um the image itself is a buffer on the
GPU so if we if we do like the
alternative would be us scaling it
ourselves but that's silly we can just
let the GPU upscale it when it gets
rendered like we were originally doing
um in which case we could also just have
basically the renderer arm
provide like you know get with which
would return width and get height
which would return height
um and then this just gets replaced with
uh renderer get with and renderer get
high so hopefully that makes sense
um now this though this situation
doesn't really need to exist this if
check because you can see we're kind of
doing that already in resize if needed
that's why we called it resize if needed
because it does do a check here before
it goes ahead and resizes which means we
can just Chuck that in kind of and have
it run every frame because it's only
going to resize if it is needed so we
can do resize if needed with obviously
scaled window width and scaled window
height because that's the one that's
divided by three we might play with the
scaling and change the way it works
because at the moment what might happen
is uh it might not necessarily make our
um like it might actually kind of
increase the bounds of our world in a
way because we're physically going to
have more pixels to render so whereas we
probably want to make things bigger so
we probably want this number three to be
dependent on like how much how many
tiles of the world we want to show in
one view so we will probably play with
that later
um yeah and then this whole section goes
away so we just have image now it's
important you can see we do this first
and then we do resize if needed because
if we do that first it's going to delete
our old image potentially and then we'll
render nothing we'll render random
pixels or something weird so we always
want to do that first and then even if
this does resize our image and delete it
since we've already submitted that it's
not going to delete the image from the
GPU memory in like uh immediately it's
gonna like defer that and cue it up so
that eventually
um when it comes time to when it's
definitely already been used and
rendered like that submission's over and
we we're ready for a fresh image it will
do the actual freeing of that image then
so basically what I'm saying is it'll
keep that old image around until it's
definitely no longer used which is quite
useful and that's just something Walnut
does for us okay
um yeah so I mean this obviously we
could kind of make this still work but
we'll move that to the renderer I think
um image set data yeah that's no longer
necessary but that does mean though that
we do have to set the data at some point
in here
so
um what I want to do is I'm going to
make a function called prepare
which I call it prepare
um
I don't know if it should be called
prepare
I'll I'll just say update image Maybe
so update image is a function that I
guess will basically just go ahead and
do image set data image buffer because
that needs to be done basically before
the reason I wanted to call it prepare
is because it needs to be done before we
actually get uh image but I don't want
to Chuck it into this function because
we might want to do this multiple times
per frame but really this only needs to
be done once per frame
um so it is a bit annoying but we have
to make sure we do render or update
image basically as soon as we're done
rendering using the renderer that can go
away that was just boilerplate kind of
on a boil plate stuff but uh explanation
stuff from the previous episode and now
we have our first kind of thing where we
want to be able to maybe render a sprite
from this Sprite sheet now the
spreadsheet itself is somewhat static
right there's only one of the one
instance of this ever
um so we can just basically give access
to that because we have obviously a
static game layer get what we can do
though is we can give access to that
spreadsheet by just having a getter for
it
so get Sprite sheet and we could
obviously shove this into like a
resource manager but that I would say is
almost over engineering it a little bit
because it just you don't need to have
all these abstract classes or whatever
so you can see this is not static but
because this is static it gives us
access to a game layer instance that can
then access everything that's public and
not static obviously uh so now that we
have that
um oh yeah the problem is going to be
that because game layer is actually in
this CPP file
right it's going to kind of mean that we
can't access it because we don't have a
debt we don't have a declaration of it
that's accessible inside renderer.cvp so
now would be a good time to go over here
and actually make that be
um
and I might just call it game so it's
almost mimicking the game that we had
here because you can see we have a main
class kind of called game which actually
has the main function similar to that
um we'll make a game CBP file as well
uh namespace Genesis
include game.h
um okay and then what this is going to
be obviously is this entire game layer
class I'll we'll deal with that instance
a bit later I'll cut that I'll paste it
here
will include
um walnuts
layer so there's obviously I'm pasting
into the header file and then what I'm
going to do is uh what's the simplest
way it is probably just to copy all of
these guys
except the stuff that's kind of fine to
be in line
um and then I'm going to paste it in
here and then all I have to do is add
that gameplay namespace and that way I'm
kind of implementing every function
except I did want it to be called game
but we'll we can make that adjustment
later
so then I'll get rid of overrated stuff
because that's only in the Declaration
of the definition
uh but yeah that way we can easily
retain the bodies of all of our
functions
um back in Genesis app we'll grab
uh where was I'm gooey even implemented
because it's not here
maybe it was in Walnut application which
we probably don't need
yeah I wonder where that was I guess I'm
gooey.h is what we're looking for though
so back in game I'll include that
um we still need yeah render and
everything uh I wonder why that's not
just popping up though
oh well we need to yeah we need to get
rid of
these so we're kind of reducing that to
be
um just declarations this should be
virtual by the way there's no real
difference because layer in layer is
declared virtual so it'll automatically
be virtual here even if you don't
declare it like that but I'm
specifically declaring it like that
because I want it to be
um
obvious that it is virtual I don't know
why that's upset but we'll get to that
later
um okay so this again we're just nuking
all of the bodies
and adding semicolons because they've
become declarations uh shared pointer
again with the dot h
um Genesis Sprite sheet
probably keep this up here
so I always by the way with my include
order I always basically do the first is
always stuff that is from within my
project the second is always stuff that
is kind of within other modules but in
my in my kind of solution and then the
last part is always like the SQL plus
stand in the library just in case I have
some configurations for these headers or
whatever
um I always include my code first and
then like code that is kind of further
away from directly here
um all right so the renderer would also
go here that's probably why it just
wasn't defined there we go
um okay and then yeah image data we'll
sort that out okay so now we've kind of
moved that here we still need to deal
with this game layer instance which used
to be like this weak pointer so if we
grab that we can put put that into the
CPP file
so that kind of is the same right
um and then we can put this
here like it was before
so it does the implementation of game
like I get I think yeah I guess we can
just keep everything as is
um and that's probably okay uh so let's
quickly rename keep pinning these things
let's quickly rename this to just begame
so by the way the way I did that I
should probably explain that alt shift I
if you have visual assist I think you
can probably do it with Visual Studio as
well
um yeah control our control R seems to
work but alt shift r with little assist
and then you just give it another name
and it should update it everywhere
should being the keyword because table
plus is a complicated language and there
could be some issues in areas where it
doesn't do do the right thing basically
um okay so uh
uh what's next so clear random should
still kind of draw the background we
just need to be able to draw our player
yeah I think this episode just became
like a refactoring episode to be honest
there's just too much
stuff to do and I want to keep these
episodes manageable so
um let's do this let's kind of move that
around to Sprite in a minute and we'll
just maybe abstract it to taking a
coordinate or something
um yeah that'll probably be good
um
but otherwise is this okay so let's
include game
probably don't need any of this stuff
anymore
so this will be Jonas's game uh this can
probably be this can't be I think your
namespace Genesis because of this but if
we wanted to we could using namespace
journalists within this
um oh and then we have to assign the
game layer instance so that needs to
happen uh
yeah because it's a shared pointer as
well so we have to assign it from
outside of that class okay that's a
little bit annoying um it's definitely
not like a deal breaker or anything uh
because we could just add like an API
here
um that lets us do that so
how would we do that
would be an elegant way to do that
I mean we could even
okay I'm gonna show you guys something a
little bit wild and a little bit messy
we could actually keep this in the
Genesis app class again this is our card
as well so it's not a big deal
but we're keeping this here and
obviously assigning It Here and Now what
we need to do is obviously implement
this uh get function but what I can do
is I can just not Implement instead of
implementing game get in here in the
game class I can actually like include
that definition in this class which
looks a little bit wild because it's
like oh shouldn't that be in the game
like thing right and obviously this
needs the namespace
um and the answer is no not really uh
and I would probably even just put this
into instead of putting you know Genesis
everywhere here I probably would put
this into
the Genesis namespace like that to just
avoid having all of this and make it
look like it's part of genesis's code
right but that's kind of all all there
everything works as usual because again
at the end of the day all of these CPP
files they're just kind of
they get linked into one program binary
so it doesn't really matter where the
definitions are as long as they're
somewhere and the Linker can find them
so that it can patch up the functions
correctly so that's all that really
matters
[Music]
um
so yeah so that's fine and that
obviously means that we don't have to
like create some weird API function here
that's like oh you know set instance or
whatever else uh because there's in a
way there's no reason for it to be here
as long as it's somewhere and
genesisapp.cbp I think it's a perfectly
fine place to have that kind of instance
okay beautiful so now the renderer
should be able to access that and if we
go into game we can take out our render
Sprite situation I'll change this to be
something like m renderer
well we had a draw Sprite
um so maybe if we uh go to that function
and just paste it in I missed I missed
um we can just set this to be M width
and M height
so Sprite should get pixels so we should
probably get the Sprite sheet um and we
can do that just by just writing Auto
Sprite sheet equals game get and then
get Sprite sheet
we'll have to include game here
I'm gonna include that before Walnut
stuff
um yeah and then we can just do spray
tree get pixels and whatever else we
want
okay image data is our image buffer
that's the only real difference that
still seems to work
yeah that looks pretty good to me so
that is a way for us to draw that same
Sprite hopefully
um and game obviously kind of triggers
that we do game game uh with a render
address bright then we update the image
to get onto the GPU uh we do only
resizing if it's necessary and we do
draw the image kind of at the at the
appropriate image scale so let's just
hit our five let's see what happens and
hopefully this will work
okay uh I forgot the random
the the random and make sure we do that
first actually clear random because
otherwise it's um yeah there you go
because otherwise it's obviously going
to draw the random pixels on top of our
player which I have lost here he is okay
um cool I think I'm a little bit over
clear random so we might just do clear
and should we have a clear color I guess
we can have a you know
clear color which I will just set to
maybe Zero by default or maybe it should
be ff000 so it's kind of full Alpha not
that it really matters I think
I don't know it might
um we'll create that implementation
and that will basically do the same
thing I might just collapse these
parentheses or the curly brackets rather
and we'll just set this obviously to
clear color so there you go
clearing image buffer to clear color
um so now if we just do clear
and then like you know I could put in a
custom color here like pink Let's do
let's do that purple color
it's a little bit easy on the eyes
um we'll see if this works yep
um and obviously we can just clear with
no parameter and that will be clearing
it to Black
uh and there we go there's our player in
a world of Darkness okay last thing I
want to do today is draw Sprite let's
actually provide it with some kind of
coordinates so at the moment you can see
it draws just two and eight or two seven
that happens to be what we picked here
but what I want to do is basically allow
us to uh you know kind of Supply an X
index and a y index for the Sprite that
we want to draw within the Sprite sheet
now obviously this is probably not final
API stuff because it's a bit annoying to
refer to your Sprites by a coordinate
you'd want them to find somehow
um but you know for now that's obviously
fine so XC and Y C is kind of what that
is I can just could just Pat you know
get rid of these variables patch you
know everywhere with X index Y and X or
I can just set them here again the
compiler is going to just sort that out
for you so two and seven is what we were
using so if we go back here now we're
forced to provide like a parameter such
as two seven
uh and you can see it works um now
there's a few flaws here uh but first
let's try to draw something that will
work so in Sprites
um let's maybe draw should we draw the
torch let's roll the torch so that
should be just number one and zero
so one on Y and zero on X to give us the
torch uh okay so first of all we get
that purple border that's easy to fix
obviously it's because for for whatever
reason again the Sprite sheet um has
cells marked here I guess just so we
could see where stuff ends maybe but
it's in a different color it's in that
kind of purple color which is
7f007f so what we could have done is
just you know put pink everywhere here
so that we would have one but since
we've decided not to modify the original
Sprite sheet we can go into renderer and
just basically uh you know when we
render anything like this we could just
say that if color is pink or purple
continue
very easy obviously so 7f and 7f
and that will get us a perfect torch as
you can see
um it's very easy for us as well to you
know draw this in a different place so
we could draw the torch let's draw the
player first and then the torch
um
on top of it and by different place I
really just meant uh we can draw
multiple Sprites very easily by just
doing that more than once
um but then the other functionality we
probably want is where on the screen do
we render that Sprite
um and that I think we're going to say
for next episode because uh I want to
probably introduce the camera or
something to make that happen
and was that all that oh yeah the
problem so if we decide to do something
stupid like 20 which is outside of the
bounds of the supply chain
um we're gonna I was gonna say we're
gonna crash but we didn't crash
um
not really sure why let's have a look at
what actually happened oh actually well
yeah we probably should have crashed it
probably just wrapped around to a
different part of the buffer or
something maybe but basically if we
specify an X index that's completely
high right then 20 by that that's going
to be the wrong coordinate and so when
we initially like we'll be at a
different region of this kind of sprite
sheet pixels buffer if that makes sense
so
um what we should do
is the Sprite shade should probably like
it has a width and a height and if you
exceed that like it probably shouldn't
draw anything so when it multiplies this
with the Sprite sheet we could just do a
little check to see if XB is less than
zero or XP is greater than or equal to
um
well that that's the starting coordinate
as well so if XP is greater than uh or
equal to what should we do we should do
I think so Sprite sheets
uh gets width
let's just get it up here maybe
Sprite shade width
I did surprise size here and the Sprite
shade height
get height
so if it's basically spreadsheet width
minus uh Sprite size because I think
that'll be out of bounds as well
um or
uh
the same thing but with Y and Heights
everywhere whoops
so y p y p so that then we can basically
return but it'd be nice to print like a
little message
being like
you know
uh
Sprite oh my goodness what's going on
Sprite index
X
um that's what am I doing then
come on
um comma y index
is out of bounds
so we won't draw it but we will print a
message which we need to include i o
stream for
um that will just kind of you know tell
us that we're doing something wrong we
could even assert here or break or
whatever uh if we wanted to see but you
can see we get a nice little message
that just tells us that's out of bounds
and it won't draw it because that could
crash or you know cause a memory access
violation or best case scenario I guess
draw the wrong Sprite Which we don't
need so if we clear that we should be
pretty good Okay so we've just kind of
spent today I guess reorganizing stuff
uh we've done quite a lot of
reorganization we've introduced this
renderer obviously it seems to work
resizing I didn't really test but I'm
sure that will work considering it would
have had to resize on like the first
frame so you can see that works fine uh
it doesn't make anything bigger as you
can see so this is the same size player
as this so instead what we're doing is
we're just allowing us to see more space
so we're kind of adding more resolution
which is kind of like what you would
want from like a desktop system but
maybe not from a game now necessarily
you might want that from a game but
maybe not from this game because it will
make it easier in a way you'll see more
and you'll know where the females are so
you can find them so uh yeah anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode don't
forget to hit the like button if you did
and I'll see you next time goodbye